[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mesdames et messieurs francis ford
coppola
robert de niro
al pacino
[Applaudissements]
à
je pense que des instants comme ceux ci
doivent être sincère et donc bref et je
suis ravi que mes deux amis puissent
être sur scène avec moi pour célébrer
pour rendre hommage à ce projet qu'on a
démarré il ya 50 ans avec des
collaborateurs qui sont des légendes et
nombre d'entre eux sont connus vous
toutes et tous on n'a pas le temps de
tous les remercier mais je vais en
remercier deux quand même ce qu avait
d'abord ou un collaborateur
a déjà été remerciés des dizaines de
fois et des convois le parent on voit
son nom c'est mario puzzo
une autre personne qui pour le coup n'a
jamais été remercié mais le temps est
venu parce que c'est grâce à sa
participation de ce jeune
ces décisions que le film a pu avoir
lieu robert edberg
que
même si beaucoup plaire et bibliothèques
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]